hey everybody it's your friend adam i'm
here uh with jonathan pujo we've been
talking about having a conversation for
a while and my fans are dying for me to
talk to you just so you know
like that's everybody i've been seeing
you for
years like just especially i mean since
the jordan peterson thing happened i've
been seeing
your videos watching a few videos and
just kind of seeing you around with paul
vander clay and
and different people so i'm happy to
talk to you finally yeah i'm i'm a
pro christianity uh
atheist so i i'm definitely i'm hated on
both sides
often so i'm much less hated by the
christians because obviously i'm a pr
i'm pro-christianity i grew up christian
so i feel qualified to talk about
christianity because i grew up
within the religion i grew up southern
baptist and though i
kind of grew into atheism because of my
being a fan of science and evolution and
all that kind of stuff i've
sort of become an atheist i still
understand the value of
christianity and an ethical system and
an ethical package
and really the people that despise me
are what i call the antithesis
which i like to separate the atheists
from the antithesis because atheists
just lack
a belief in god a lot of times
antitheists
will say well an atheist atheism is just
a lack of belief in god and i'll think
yes that's true
but you have a belief in something
different you're an antithesis you
believe the world would be a better
place without religion like that's the
central
motivating feature of your ideology i do
not believe the world would be a better
place without religion
i lack a belief in god i'm an atheist
you're an antithesis like
so i make that separation that
distinction but we were talking a little
bit before we started about you you
recently did
a a a talk with rationality rules
and i listened to that talk i thought it
was interesting but i i
agree that with some of the people
saying that there was a little bit of
talking past one another
so i thought you know our it made me
want to have a conversation with you
even more because i thought
we're probably less likely to talk past
one another
ironically like rationality rules
uh made this video completely savaging
me
i made some response videos to him and i
thought he and i would have a
constructive dialogue
uh that never happened like i'm closer
to
uh his position uh uh
like he did a video recent it's funny
because okay so let me give the back
story here i
because yeah i didn't know about this
story i didn't know this has happened so
rationality rules was making jordan
peterson videos uh
and just straw manning the hell out of
jordan peterson it was driving me crazy
it was driving my fans crazy
so they wanted me to do response videos
because i understand jordan peterson's
argument
jordan peterson's argument is
surprisingly close to
uh brett weinstein's argument about
metaphorical truth
so i'm doing these videos explaining how
uh rationality rules is completely straw
manning the argument here
uh later on rationality rules does a
video where he's all in favor of
metaphorical truth and i'm like
why like why are you crapping all over
jordan peterson if you're in favor of
what jordan peterson is talking about
just
you're not necessarily understanding it
so so we i made some response videos to
him
he made a response video to me basically
just dismissing me as some
internet troll and i'm like i've been on
youtube longer than you man i know
everyone on youtube i don't necessarily
understand
where you're coming from so i thought we
were uh i would have some kind of a
constructive dialogue with him about
this stuff
but it's it's funny to me that now he's
kind of making videos
that are my position so so
uh that's actually a good thing like in
the long run if he's going to come
around to my position anyway regardless
of whether or not we get along
i'm comfortable with that but you
evidently have a problem with his
position
and um well i i saw him i had been
i've seen his videos like just anyway
you know i've seen all a lot of the
different types of atheists and
different types of
i you know people who have different
ideologies on youtube for years uh
you know i've been i've been now on
youtube for about four years
and i'd seen his videos and his kind of
um his auntie jordan peterson videos i
had written one comment on
his one of his videos saying that i
think that he misunderstands the
argument
um and we had a little bit of an
exchange on one of the videos but then i
thought
i don't think we could understand each
other and then recently i did see his
video on
brett weinstein's metaphorical truth
right and i was really surprised at some
of the things he was saying and i
thought oh wait actually so if
if he can find some ground in brett
weinstein's
argument then maybe there could be a
point of contact where we could talk
at least at least kind of try to
to understand each other because until
then i felt like we'd probably
completely talk past each other and uh
and that he has been really
super gracious like i he was extremely
generous we had a um
private conversation first to kind of to
just say okay look this is what i'm
going to say like
we don't we weren't trying the idea was
like we don't want to trap each other
like that's not the point you really
want to try to explore the ideas
um and it's been it's been really
positive for me at least the
the conversation has been positive i do
feel like you said that in the
conversation
a few things happened i think one thing
one thing that happened was we did end
up talking past each other on certain
points and i feel like he didn't he
didn't he hadn't realized the extent to
which i'm actually a christian
and then i think that that surprised him
and so then he was kind of taken off
guard because
you know at some point he he says
something like wait so you really
believe in god
and i was like well yeah you know and
then and i think that that surprised a
little bit because
because i think he saw me more on jordan
peterson's side let's say
um but but uh but yeah in the end in the
end
i i do feel if you watch the comment
sections on both
our channels it's clear that we
we are still talking way past each other
because it's very
radicalized like the com the comment
sections
like on my side they're saying he didn't
understand what i was saying and on his
side they're saying i'm just trying to
speak around
you know i'm just i'm just just
basically saying things to justify my
christian position and not
not really you know engaging with the
argument so so it's too bad
well i don't know like for me it was
like a test it was like i'm gonna
find the person that i feel is kind of
the furthest from my position
that i could actually talk to and then
and then try to see if we can understand
each other
so i'm not sure i'm not sure it happened
but i'm not totally
giving up yet let's say well personal
feelings aside
i think he's cultivated an audience of
antitheists i i
harp on this distinction all the time
because it's so important he has an
audience that
wants to believe the world would be a
better place without religion
even the lgbt stuff came in in your talk
with him
like a lot of those people who are
antitheists or lgbt activists
they feel religion is dangerous
to the lb lgbt movement and maybe they
have an argument there
like i don't necessarily uh disagree
with them
in america we have this thing and i'm
sure it's the same you're in canadian
right
in canada i'm sure it's pretty much the
same thing like if if you're lgbt and
the
and uh the church has prohibitions on
lgbt then
you can leave the church like nobody's
forcing you to stay there this isn't uh
you know islam or anything like that
like uh go
enjoy your life without the church so i
i as long as it's not being forced upon
you i feel like
they have less of an argument there so
but
but um one of the things that i thought
we could talk about that would be
more interesting is that i feel like i
could get
past some of the talking past
one another that you had with him
because i
i the the thing about uh steve or
rationality rules whatever he's calling
himself these days uh
you if that i'm not sure that he can
win that audience over but he has more
of a chance of winning that audience
over than either
either you or i have and i know that
when he was making response videos to
jordan peterson they very much saw
jordan peterson as just like this bible
thumper that was
winning people over to christianity but
the reason jordan peterson was winning
people over to christianity i think is
because
he was putting a rationalist
scientific spin on christianity that
made it make sense for a lot of people
who were scientifically minded
uh atheist types so it was just a
misunderstanding that rationality rules
had
about jordan peterson that a lot of my
response videos were
were trying to explain and um
i i it's funny that you were probably
closer to the type of person that he
thought jordan peterson was
then i think george people i'm more like
an actual i go to church i
totally don't go to church now because
of coped but like in the normal world i
go
totally yes you know and i pray and i
have
i have taken on all the traditional
practices of a christian like that's for
sure do you think jordan
because we have you know this running
back going with jordan peterson is like
is jordan peterson really just an
like an atheist that uh you know
understands christianity but he just
doesn't want to say he's an atheist
because he loses all his street cred
i believe jordan peterson is probably
closer to the atheist position
i think that he's the thing this is the
thing about jordan
is that jordan is what you see there is
there are no two jordan petersons and
that's something
you know that is important for people to
understand is that
it whatever you see of him none of it is
like a show
if you see him hesitating on a question
it's because he's hesitating on a
question
he's not doing it he's not doing it as a
as a
as a way to to to play a game like
i i had a conversation i mean i haven't
talked to him a lot
you know recently yeah because of the
house sick and everything but i had a
conversation
with him uh maybe about a year and a
half ago
where he started talking about genesis
again and
he he was just he was just like
wrestling with the the thing like
wrestling with the story and
and then he he says what if these
stories really were true like what if
they were true and he was
excited about it on the phone and i was
like are you
like really like i was like come on man
like i thought we i thought like from my
side i thought we were past this you
know
but i think he's really kind of he's
really uh wrestling with these questions
existentially
and so that's what it is so i so i think
that he's not an
atheist but i think that he doesn't he
doesn't
have faith let's say it that way
that is there's a difference between
saying
there's a difference between saying that
you believe that
god refers to something which it has
value let's say
something like that or and faith which
is
a celebration of
that which is above you and a
participation in that story
so those two things are different so do
you want to
get into your conception of god
first of all just since we're talking
about the the
the rationality rules talk is there
anything that you'd like to say that you
felt
well wasn't said there or what after
you've had some time to reflect on it
what
what are some of your afterthoughts well
for sure i really
i do feel like i i wasn't like i wasn't
able to communicate what i wanted
and so and it's been helpful to be
honest like it's been helpful to watch
paul vander clay did a comment on the
talk and i've been reading
his comment section in my comment
section and so it's been i think it's
going to help me in the end because
you know these things are hard to talk
about and so i feel like i wasn't able
to communicate
one basic thing which is that i can
maybe
summarize it this way which is that i
have
a cosmological frame and this
cosmological frame
is actually universal it actually isn't
limited to christianity
christianity has some key
puzzle elements of that cosmological
frame which i think are
extremely important i would say make
christianity
ext you know truer than anything else
but the frame itself is the same in
taoism and in hinduism
and and in all the religions like it's a
basic cosmological frame
and that and the the the applications of
that pattern
are what cause all the rules in terms of
morality that i
believe in and so
if you're going to argue against some
moral position
in the christian in the christian world
view
then you have to be able to tell me what
it is
first of all from which position are you
arguing that
because i know like i have a i have a
whole pattern
that tells me how a pattern that is as
useful to
my moral positions than they are to how
i build houses
and how you build cities and how you
organize government all of these things
come down from this cosmological pattern
there's variety it's not a totalitarian
thing there's variety
so if you're gonna tell me that this
moral position of christianity is wrong
then you have to be able to argue your
frame to me
not just this position and you also have
to be able to tell me what is the good
you're aiming towards
because i know what the good i'm aiming
towards is
whether i succeed or not we can argue
about the application
and say this application doesn't lead to
that goal but if you're going to tell me
that you it's not good enough and you
need something better
you have to tell me what the better is
and i feel like that's the
that's the place where we were stuck
where i was saying
if you if you're telling me it's this
this aspect of christianity is
inadequate
then you have to be able to tell me
towards what i need to modify it
to if i'm going to modify it towards
what is it liberty
is it equality is it uh what is the
value i don't know i'm not sure i could
understand what that is is it
comfort is it more people alive and less
people dying
is what is it like what is the thing
you're aiming towards what is the telos
and so i think that that's that was
where to me at least it stuck
and we were unable to kind of get past
that but i feel like it's maybe because
i didn't articulate
enough the idea that that
i don't care as much about the the
particular laws and rules that you don't
like in christianity
because the frame is so powerful
that i'm willing to even accept some
things that i might disagree on in
detail
because because it's worth to keep this
frame and to live
inside this story and to participate in
these communities
it's worth it to accept a few things
that i might even disagree with
i should i forgot to mention too that
we're both artists so i think
i think i think we have that in common
but just back on the
on the topic the arguing against the
morality i think
like i've hung out with these people
enough and you know i'm sort of
tacitly part of their tribe i think they
would say something to the effect of
of you know truth uh scientific truth
materialist truth has a higher
higher survival value just because of
they always want to point to medical
advancements and things like that
that uh go
putting all of our eggs in the
metaphorical truth basket
would be uh more detrimental to
the survival of more people than to
focus
on scientific truth so i think that is
really their biggest disagreement or
argument against your ethical package
that i i think that they would pull out
so what so let
so this is something that has come up
with brett weinstein as well
which is so on the one hand you have
this evolutionary
thinking and this this like basic
scientific
thinking which is also bound up in
evolutionary thinking
and these two things are strangely bound
up together
and and so
what i hear is on the one hand i hear
people saying that scientific truth is
the highest it's the most important
and then i hear at the same time the
same people saying
we need to break our evolutionary code
we need to move out of our evolutionary
code because it's dangerous
because it leads to genocide because it
leads to rape because it leads to
all of these horrible tribalistic things
and so
they're saying we need to be able to now
to now
transcend our evolutionary impulses
and my question is again towards what
like where are you standing like if
you're if you're not then in the
evolutionary camp
and you're in another camp then tell me
what's your camp
like tell me where you are and what
you're aiming towards what do you
think the evolutionary camp is let's
because you're a believer in evolution
right
i mean you're not i i think evolution
happened i don't know if i believe it
okay what would you or believe in it how
about if i
said i i don't really believe in it but
i i don't mind it
so maybe we're just talk i don't want to
talk past each other like
yeah so you you believe evolution by
natural selection
is happening today uh you know the
origin of species you believe in that
right i think i definitely think that
you think it's true i guess it's
powerful it's a very powerful process
that has been
brought to light in the last you know
few centuries believe is a tough term i
think that's a term we're getting hung
up on
you you think uh you accept that it's
true that evolution is happening
evolution by natural selection
yeah i'll say yes that that's fine what
is it i didn't say yes
that's okay reproduction variation
selection i think is
what you can nail it down to okay this
also happens culturally do you accept
that
that i think so culture cultural
evolution happens through the same
process right
a bunch of people think let's let's try
something different
let's all switch our genders and form a
commune and see what happens
maybe this will be a successful cultural
adaptation if it's not successful if it
doesn't reproduce offspring it dies out
and that cultural
uh mutation dies correct same way as
uh organisms themselves uh reproduce and
die
yeah well that that that that has some
even in evolutionary terms that has a
there's a problem because there's a
limited amount of energy you can expound
sure totally most evolutionary processes
are actually hyper conservative
very much so because you have very
little energy and if you
start to ex you start to put all your
energy in these experimental forms
then you're going to be dead before you
have the time to even know whether or
not
all these forms you're trying to
experiment with will be going to be
fruitful and this is the best argument
against the celebrity atheists like
dawkins and harris and those guys
because
like religion is all these costly has
all these costly features to it
uh evolution is the best argument that
religion is doing
something useful evolutionarily or why
would it exist it's
all we're we're expending all these
costly energies
you know going to church helping people
meeting other
uh you know meeting together forming
coalitions all of that stuff
has to be evolutionarily advantageous
somehow because
as as religion leaves the public sphere
then the birth rate goes down so
sure exactly that too that too so
so you you are probably in agreement
with brett weinstein that evolution
or that religion is some sort of of
extended phenotype i think is the way
that he referred to it in his talk with
richard dawkins
which doesn't bother me like i obviously
do not view the world primarily in
evolutionary terms
right like i i interpret the
evolutionary terms based on
i i think that the the frame the cosmic
frame that is given
by let's say traditional society is more
powerful
than that but i i don't mind it like in
the sense that i
that i i think it's fine you know i
think it's okay but i i think that
when you try to apply these types of
patterns to
religious thinking what happens is you
catch a few things
like you catch a few things that are
true and a few things connect
so you look at the rules in the
scripture and you and you're like oh i
can explain this through this really
this evolutionary process i can explain
this but then there's like 80 percent of
it that you still think is nonsense
but even if you do believe that it's a
it's like this emergent thing that
happened
then it it needs for it to have been
selected for
it needs to have some coherence or at
least some
some some application so are you talking
about christianity specifically
total nonsense for thousands of years
you know
i don't think that that that's true and
and the frame that i'm trying to
to explain to people make sense of it
all
like it doesn't none of it falls up
falls to the side there's nothing in
scripture
which falls to the side if you use the
basic cosmic pattern
that that that you find that you find in
religion itself
okay the i'm not i'm not completely
sure what you're meaning on the cosmic
pattern but we'll get back to it because
i just
if well i i want you the
some one thing that can't came up
continuously in your talk with
rationality rules was like the goal
the what's good that kind of stuff so
yeah i just think
you know as as impartial observers of
evolution like we both
believe it's uh
reproduction variation selection what is
the
goal of reproduction variation selection
in the context of physical organisms
to me it seems like it has to be
something on par with utilitarianism
like
the most well-being for the largest
number of people and it's
it's perspective oriented because it is
going to be
the you know obviously what's good for
us is not necessarily what's good for
chimpanzees like there's a reason why
humans have dominated this planet and
chimpanzees have not right
but why is it the most good for the most
people i really can't get there with
evolutionary thinking because because it
can be to your advantage to
to massively dominate other populations
evolutionary
like in an evolutionary way it's it's
way it's your advantage to
completely dominate the other lines yes
no i agree so that your line
is disadvantaged i agree that's why i
specifically said that it's perspective
oriented because obviously the
utilitarian
argument for lions is going to be
different than the utilitarian argument
for human beings
because the most good for the most
people is different than the most good
for the most
lions the most good for the most lines
is the frame of reference for a lion
though they're obviously
they would like to be in the humanity
role right now
and lions will eat the offspring of
other lions if they
if yes that is actually that is actually
a bad thing in the utilitarian argument
because
the the the most thriving
for the most uh organisms in that
um in that uh uh
species is going to help because you've
got to admit
that numbers matters especially in an
evolutionary game
so while different uh different
speed different humans formed different
tribes that competed against
other tribes a bigger tribe always had a
better advantage correct
like if i have 100 people versus 10
people obviously you put your money on
100 people right well not always i don't
think that's why i know
obviously that's also why that's why you
have
moments in history where the small like
mongolian tribe comes in
and savages the chinese empire why
though why what what what is the
advantage that they have over the
numbers
the technological advantage or
flexibility okay so they have a better
ethical system sorry so they have a
better ethical system a better a better
strategy
like everything or they have a better
system
to dominate because when you have let's
say you have a
a system which is too big then it it had
lacked flexibility and so when
the bigger it gets the more chance you
have of a small thing coming in
and piercing the bubble right and
because it has massive flexibility
then it can wiggle itself into into a
space and take over
but if you have two teams like that and
one has a superior
i i'm just i call it an ethical system
because that's basically what ethical
systems are they're the rules
of engagement between a group so if that
group has a rule
has a ethical system that allows them
to form a bond of 10 guys that can beat
a hundred guys
that ethical system everyone's going to
look at and go that's a good ethical
system i think we should adopt it
and pretty soon that 10 guys is a
hundred guys
and they can beat a thousand people
right yeah so that ethically a thousand
then there's another ten guys
with a different with a different
ethical system maybe the ethical system
will change
as society's that's why societies change
as you as you get rich and as you get
as you in stabilize then your world is
going to start to look like what you are
it's you can't just you can't you can't
be uh
you know it's like jordan it's like you
can't be a boxer
a super aggressive boxer if if
if at some point you stop
fighting for your life like at some
point you're going to lose your edge you
need to find ways to keep your edge
but it's going to happen all it's going
to happen by itself right it's just
going to
could be part of your success is going
to be that you're going to lose that
edge that you had at the beginning it's
just a normal cycle of things
well i i view christianity and and
different religions
as these ethical systems that are
uniting people and
and allowing people to uh
cooperate with one another that that's
the way that i see these ethical systems
so so what if we could say that it's not
an ethical system
i don't think christianity and i don't
think religions are ethical systems i
think that
that's one of the problems which makes
it hard for people to understand
religion
is because if you think that they're
really if they're an ethical system
then you don't understand why you have
to build an ark of the covenant and have
two angels
with their wings touching and you don't
understand why you need
to to uh to have you know veils around
holy places all of this stuff makes no
sense if it's just an ethical system
you know it's it's actually more than an
ethical system it's a
it's a frame of reality it's a it's a
way to understand
value and to understand not to
understand but to participate
in hierarchies of being okay so that
so that these hierarchies lay themselves
out and create units
so it has more to do with identity than
it has to do with ethics
has more to do with who you are what
your place is in the world
and what's your relationship with others
and then downstream from that
you have rules and regulations and and
let's say ways of acting
but at first it's like we worship the
thing that unites us
we celebrate the thing that unites us
just like a a basketball team
will celebrate their their logo their
mascot
that the the they will find rituals
to cohere and they'll have a totem like
a mascot that will go out into the crowd
and get everybody to cheer for the team
that's the most important part it has to
do with
identification and and uh social
cohesion through
participative identity more than
the moral stuff the moral stuff comes
down downstream from that once you
understand
that then a lot of religious stuff is
going to make way more sense to you
you know you're going to understand what
people gather together why they sing
together why they pray
together whether they look in the same
direction why they eat a meal together
all of these things are manifestations
of participat
participation in the same identity under
a god
under uh something which unites them an
identity which unites them together
well i i i from an evolutionary frame
all of this makes complete sense so it's
it's i can understand it from my frame
and i think you can understand it from
my frame
i don't um i don't know
that i completely understand what you're
talking about
from your frame well no and that's
that's i mean that's
that's the goal here right i mean what
is what is what is your goal what are
you
what are you trying to accomplish with
your youtube channel and you're
just talking about this kind of stuff so
what i'm noticing
in the world is a breakdown
there's a breakdown going happening
there's a fragmentation of
identities there's a fragmentation of
of all the places which in which we find
our communion or in which we find unity
are breaking down
and people are just surfing through
surfing as if this is normal but at some
point
it's going to move towards more chaos
riots all of this stuff the chaos that
we see
that we saw in in 2020 and it's also
going to move towards
authoritarian clampdowns because one of
the problems which happens when normal
identity starts to fragment
is that there's an over compensation on
the other side
and so what i'm seeing down line is very
dark
there's a very dark uh horizon
and one of the reasons why it is is
because we've ceased to understand what
makes things exist as one like
why do we think that nations have
identity
why do we think families why do we think
a person has
unity and this is because we've lost the
cosmic frame
we've lost the frame this traditional
hierarchy of being which
which is shown in the temple in the
church in the in the story of
genesis and all of these images that
help us to understand and participate
in how things are won jordan talks about
this all the time which is
the problem of john vervicky uses the
words combination
combinatorial explosion there's too much
stuff in the world
like there's just too much phenomena and
so there are ways in which phenom
phenomena coalesces into identities in
which you're able to see
that uh a chair has parts but is also
one
like why do we think that a chair is one
thing it's not one thing it's
a million things it's and why do you
think that that chair
is participates with other furniture and
we can see it as one room and why
do we see one room as one house or one
house as one
you know these all these houses as one
city there are processes by which this
is possible
and if we attack ritual and we attack
the notion of concentric spaces or the
idea of
the way in which society communes then
it's going to become
the suburbs all of reality is going to
become the suburbs it's going to become
a flat
a flat a distribution of particles
that have no coherence it's going to
happen in the way we build houses it's
going to happen in our morality where
everybody has their own morality
it's going to happen in our identities
where everybody has their own identity
and there's nothing
joining us together and we're going to
not know our neighbors which is already
happening
we don't know our neighbors we don't
know the people next to us we have
nothing binding us there's no glue
and that glue is ritual it's based on
concentric it's based on worshiping
the same thing no i i have to celebrate
the same thing in order to be together
this is jordan peterson's uh idea of god
god is the thing that you orient
yourself towards and
different communities orient themselves
towards different things like i would
say
the social justice community is oriented
towards
uh fighting for the rights of the
oppressed that is technically their god
because that's what they're orienting
themselves the antitheists they orient
themselves towards
the world would be a better place
without religion that is their god that
is the god that they serve every day
with every video that they make they're
trying to turn
everyone else into anti-theists well
actually
and you know by extension into
scientists because they worship
truth they think religion is bad because
it doesn't
worship uh truth over over well-being
even though it's funny that actuality is
what they worship
well but you said one thing i think i
think i want to go back to the
the fragmentati you see fragmentation
as a problem i'm torn over whether or
not the fragmentation is due to material
conditions
or whether it's due to uh philosophical
breakdown i think there's good arguments
for both but i
they're going to they go together yeah
they do they kind of feed off of one
another because you're
in christ that's why christianity has an
ascetic
aspect to it right the idea that we
accumulate all this stuff we think that
it's good in itself is not necessarily
not necessarily so that's see that's
where the philosophy shapes the material
conditions because
if you're living in horrible material
conditions it's helpful to have a
philosophy
that makes you enjoy not having anything
well the guy monks could live in very uh
lavish conditions if they wanted to they
choose not to
right like monasticism is a voluntary
choice it's not a
it's not a it's not caused by the
outside world it's
it's it's the the ascetic spirit of
christianity
is can flower even in the empire like
even if when constantinople was the most
glorious city
in the world there were still monks you
know standing on pillars and
and living in caves so the the ascetic
tendency is not
is not just based on uh material it's
not just based on a lack of material
possibility there's something else
in the ascetic thing but i just want to
say one thing about what you said in
terms of the gods
and i think you're right they really are
gods
and one of the problems we're seeing one
of the things we saw in the last few
thousand years is through christianity
through islam through judaism through
neo-platonism
and and other gr and other
versions of tradition some aspects of
hinduism like let's say
vedanta hinduism there's this idea that
the
gods stack up and so the identities of
these different things they stack up
and they they stack up towards something
which is goes moves towards a point and
you could call that point being
you could call it you know the origin
there's all ways of
of talking about it but it they stack up
so it's like you have modes of being
let's say that social justice god you
know the god of war the god of money the
god of this
you have all these gods and they're all
competing and they're competing in
society but they're also competing in
you
right so you have desires not me those
desires
are fighting amongst each other and you
can feel the same
you can see two you can feel two at the
same time right you help someone hate
them at the same time
and it's ripping you apart and so the
they say that
the christian answer and it's not just a
christian answer but
is that there's a way to unite those
into
a single mode of being which unites all
other modes of being
and that's the movement towards the
transcendent
god which who is not like all the other
gods it's not the
you can't one of the problems that
people when people
the kind of weird atheist argument which
is that like everybody's an atheist you
just believe in
you know you just believe in one more i
just one lesson
you do right yeah he's like no that's
not true i believe in all the gods i
think all the gods exist
but the the infinite transcendent is not
the same as all these
particular gods just like just like in
order to unify the different cities of
the united states you need us you need
an identity which is higher which is the
state and if you want those states not
to fight amongst each other
you need an identity hire which is the
country
and so you need these transcendent
identities in order to unify things
below them
so the in the context that i said like
uh an idea can become
a god in the sense that it's some idea
that a community orients around
social justice uh we talked about um
antitheism we talked about what would be
the i the central idea that christianity
rolls around
i i have my idea but my idea is through
an evolutionary framework obviously so
but your idea
and everything that you're saying i
don't disagree with anything that you're
saying i'm just
i'm kind of translating it into an
evolutionary framework
in my mind yeah that i i think it's love
love yeah okay and so what love love
what love does is that it is the
the balance of the unity and
multiplicity
let's see so love is when you can have
let's say
unity amongst people but that unity
doesn't
dissolve the difference the multiplicity
you know it's like if you love someone
you don't you don't like
suck them into you you don't like you
you know just like it's like like the
way that you
that you like to eat something that type
of desire that's not what
christian love is you don't you don't
make everything the same
through love you there's a a there's a
it's a there's a a recognition of the
unity
and also a recognition of the
multiplicity at the same time and it
creates this
kind of balance or this this dance
between
one and many and i think that that's
what that's what that's the the
highest value of christianity and it
manifests itself in the incarnation
where christ is seen as both
fully transcended fully god fully you
know
and at the same time fully incarnate
fully multiple
fully linked down all the way down into
death
you know and so it's like there's this
joining of of absolute fragmentation and
multiplicity in all the way to death
with the ultimate transcendent uh
principle
you're you're expert at talking in the
metaphorical truth
like so much of this is i can see this
is there since
does it sound like i'm just spouting
gibberish i hope i know a little it's
i i i can understand it and and respect
it because i respect the idea behind
metaphorical truth but i think a lot of
like scientifically minded types it
sounds like gibberish too because they
don't
they can't necessarily grab on to it
into
in a like a materialist type framework
you are talking about let me use a
scientific example
okay right and so you have a
transcendent principle
right that's you could call it uh theory
is it is it
okay so it's it's like the theory of
evolution
so that's like a yeah you have a pattern
right selection
variation uh reproduction
it it doesn't matter which one it is any
scientific theory will do
and that is a pattern and that what that
pattern does
is first of all it tells you what to
look at
because you could look at a million
things in the world sure totally so the
theory first of all frames
what you're talking about a little slice
of reality
frames the slice and then it also gives
you the parameters
by which the pattern of this thing is
going to happen okay
so that's the heaven of that
scientific thing and then there's also a
earth a lower part and that's all the
multiplicity of facts which you
encounter all the variety of facts that
the pattern creates in sort of a
fractile type sense yeah but it doesn't
just create them it also kind of
it it it uh let's say it has to
recognize them also right it's not just
about creating them because
those those pa those facts you know have
have a way of speaking like they they
they
you know and sometimes the facts will
start to contradict the theory
and so then you have to find a way to
balance
the theory with the facts correct
if you un if it's not balanced then
either the theory will like start to
crush the facts and will start to
suppress
the facts that they don't that it
doesn't like so that it will continue to
make
the theory look plausible yeah it'll
start to marginalize
facts this is where the metaphorical
truth comes in right here this is not me
this is what happens right well
definitely yeah if
it's not metaphorical it's like if this
is scientific so you you have facts and
you're
looking at them through your theory but
some of them don't fit if
a few of them don't fit that's fine
right you kind of leave them with to the
side yeah if a lot of them you start to
push them push and push them
at some point the theory is overturned
yeah it's going to split apart
and this the the theory and the facts
would just won't fit together anymore
correct yes
reality will stop to be coherent well
what they do in science so is they throw
the theory away they say that's right
we need a new theory yeah you need a
theory which is more
explains these facts better these new
facts exactly yeah
and so that but when the theory
and the facts are together
and there's a balance between the
unitive
capacity that the theory offers and the
the the variation at the bottom
that's love they see and then you go to
something that's completely subjective
completely it's not subjective
subjective well there's
different uh different types of love
there's like love love that you have for
your family and then there's love that
you have for like your wife which is
well let's let's use let's use the
christian agape love
there's love that you have for your
brother there's love that you have
for your friends the i don't disagree on
the love thing but there's a specific
aspect of the love in christianity one
of the reasons why i think christianity
has dominated the world
and and has so many adherents and so
many people
i mean going back to the example that i
have of those 10
tribes with the 10 guys with the
superior ethical system that could beat
a hundred guys
that ethical system of christianity is
spread around the world because it's so
incredibly useful especially in modern
in modern times one of the hardest
things uh
to do in society is to
uh foster an attitude of forgiveness
uh forgiveness makes the modern world
possible like
a lot of accidents happen a lot of
terrible things go on if
people aren't able to let go of those
terrible things they can consume a lot
of their
resources a lot of their family
resources a lot of their individual
resources
a lot of their tribes resources like we
have a lot of
contention going on in politics and
whatnot
until somebody has the capacity to step
up and say
okay let's start over i'm going to
forgive everything that's happened up
until then
and i encourage you to do the same let's
move forward with a fresh
slate like things can go off the rails
this is how genocides happen right yeah
things spin in the wrong direction so
but but the
center of the christian narrative is a
dude on the cross
forgiving doing this grave act
to forgive the world for all of the
injustice in it so i mean
that is a powerful idea and it
definitely plays into the love thing
that you're talking about but
it's more specific than that because it
does take a
an extreme type of love
to forgive your enemies yeah like
it's easy to love your uh you know love
your neighbor love your family
love you love your friends but to love
the guy across the street that's been a
pain in your ass
yeah like as long as you've lived there
yeah that's an extreme
type of love and i think the the uh
there's a christian narrative that like
the love your enemy thing it's important
to understand it
is that one of the problems of reality
is that the
these hierarchies let's say the
hierarchies of tribalism and the
hierarchies of
identity they're inevitable you can't
avoid them they have to exist or else
the world stops to exist the world
ceases to exist and so
how do you deal with it and so a lot of
the christian answers are
something like that which is love your
enemy and so love your enemy doesn't
mean he's not your enemy
right it's not saying this person's not
your enemy saying this person is your
enemy
but you have to find it in yourself and
you could you could you could still
defend yourself actually
like in terms of christian understanding
in terms of a country like
no christian country would ever say you
need to let yourself get invaded by
other countries
but but the idea is you need to also be
able to
continue to see the humanity of
the even the person that's attacking you
and to see that they
share something in common with you even
though
they are your enemy yeah and so and so
that's those are the kinds of answers
that christianity gives which are based
on
this finding a balance between the unity
and multiplicity like this finding this
space
where you have the best relationship
between
you know the tribal aspect and also this
openness towards the outside
all of this is all of this is manifest
itself in the incarnation
so you said one thing also in your
previous talk
that i didn't quite understand because
the argument that you seem to be making
is
which i completely agree with the only
way that you can really
change a system or a group or an
identity or
or a community is from within
and the implication that you made was
the
really you need to join christianity and
help change
christianity from within but that
argument applies to
any group i completely agree with you
that the only
the only people who are going to listen
to you are people within your tribe
uh other people will tend to dismiss you
but
until you i mean that that attitude
is uh also applies to communism which i
wouldn't
imply i wouldn't advise anyone to join
the communist community and improve it
from within
so yeah well communism is is deficient
at the outset
yeah it's a bad ethical same at all yeah
like trying to put communism on the same
level as traditional religious systems
is just really it's it's really hogwash
it's just not
it's it's really isn't uh but do you
you understand conceptualize religion as
as a thing that a people
orient around and communism is a thing
that people orient around and therefore
can be conceptualized as like a
durkheimian view
of religion can be conceptualized as a
religion it's like social justice can be
conceptualized
everything can become a religion money
can become
that's why we have the idea of idolatry
in in
christianity like how the my
i'm maybe i'm specifically i'm talking
about
a goal or a cause that a community
orients
itself around so making money
like like i don't know that money itself
can become a religion
but like um i would conceptualize any
corporation that
you know works together to make money by
doing some
service or product could be
conceptualized as a religion not
necessarily you could understand
that the god of the god of
of uh of our system is money like or
mammon and the god of the communist
system is this weird equality thing
and so it's like they worship equality
and so and
and then they want to make the world in
the image of equality
uh and it's actually probably worse than
the other one because it obviously
it self destroys in just a few
generations like it
communism doesn't just doesn't have legs
it as soon as you ins
and as soon as you put it together i
don't want to get destruction i don't
want to get sidetracked on communism
because i could very easily but the
the eye the argument about the argument
that you're
making i didn't understand and i think
other people
if i didn't understand it other people
didn't understand it so maybe you could
make it clear
what like what exactly are you
advocating for you have to understand it
in the general context of what i said i
i did
wasn't able to communicate properly
which is that
i have a cosmic mythological
frame in which i exist and participate
and
and i live in now you're standing
somewhere
and you're telling me there are aspects
of your mythological
your aspects of what you're doing which
is wrong
and and my question is
okay i i'm saying that about it no no
like
the the the the critique of the new
atheist let's say
the critique of the atheist type which
is that
this practice of christianity is is
wrong because it's factually incorrect
yes well it's not it's not about
prescriptions that are not
factual descriptions well no th but i'm
just saying that's what their critique
would be their critique would be you
believe
untrue things believing untrue things is
dangerous because the next thing you
know
you're a suicide bomber like that's
basically their argument
no am i wrong i mean that's basically
their argument
they're like if you can be tricked i'm
like uh
everyone believes untrue things there's
like you can't get out of bed without
believing untrue things because
like there's things that you don't have
the facts on
and there's also this is the thing is
that this is what
i mean we're getting sidetracked again
but there are
this is going to be hard for people to
understa to understand which is that
there are truths which are more
immediate to you
than scientific truths scientifically i
agree are
actually abstractions most of the time
do you are you
a fan of donald hoffman do you yeah okay
yeah yeah
i'm a huge donald hoffman fan so and
donald hoffman and vivek are
really going at the same kind of ideas
from different
perspectives verveiki's more on the
philosophical side and donald hoffman's
more on the scientific side so
i don't agree with him makes a mistake
he he makes a mistake
in his original premise which is fine
because he's a scientist but he makes a
mistake in his original premise which is
that we experience illusions
and and and there is this other thing
behind
which is more true than what we
experience right but we can't experience
it
and i'm like okay i don't know why don't
you posit your experience as the first
frame
and then the rest as secondary so like
the experience that we have
that's all our meaning is made out of it
like all our meaning is made out of that
experience and so
i'm not saying that scientific truths
are untrue of course they're true
but there's they're they're secondary to
that first experience
like you don't experience
h2o you drink you experience wet
you experience cold you these are the
first categories
the uh and the and they're they're not
subjective they're
personal like because they're human
experiences but everybody has similar
has it's a universal personal experience
but you don't experience molecules you
don't experience
atoms you don't experience the solar
system like you
you all of these things are not are
abstractions from your
experience and they're they're they're
useful and they're they're valuable
but they come after they come after the
first
experience well donald hoffman would say
yes
it's all experience uh so i don't
i don't disagree with you there the
just to bring it back to the
christianity thing i
do you believe the world would be a
better place if everyone was christian
is that is that your position or
why i believe that the world would be a
better place if everyone was christian
well the the
impli that's kind of the implication
when you say you know i have this frame
of reference we have
no confess what i mean is that i have
this frame
and i have ways of knowing what's good
inside of it and i have these ways of of
making it better
and you standing in a place that i don't
know where you are
like the let's say you ended my
discussion with rationality rules he's
standing in a place that i don't know
where he is
he's talking to me about a good that he
won't define
yet he's telling me that i should
improve my thing
it's like i i don't know what you want
from me like
where should i go where tell me where to
stand
tell me where to where tell me what's
your frame and then
and and help me understand it so that i
can
evaluate but for now like this seems way
superior to whatever it is you're
offering me
because you're offering me something
which is vague and imprecise and
a good that i don't that i can that i
can't really
uh identify and so it's like
this is where i am i'm speaking out of i
know what i'm speaking out of
like i know what my frame is but i don't
think you do the major contention that
came out of the dialogue there was
over the lgbt stuff he was basically
saying
uh you have an ethical package that
five percent of the population can't use
because they're
homosexual and the ethical package
just
castigates their entire lifestyle so
the ethical package is unavailable to
them
yeah i know i think that my my
difficulty with that is several fold
well he would say change your ethical
package he would say make your ethical
package inclusive of homosexual
lifestyles and we're having a
conversation
what about well no he wouldn't he
wouldn't say that because obviously
the truth would have the truth see
that's just that's just what about ism
the no it's not what about ism
we just literally said what about no but
what i mean is that
if you have to give me a reason why to
change it
i don't disagree that 20 years from now
20 years from now definitely the amount
of patterns of behavior
that exists and those indefinite amounts
of patterns of behavior can also say
why don't you accept my behavior well my
my my understanding of the world
is there are different strokes for
different folks like different people
will
utilize different ethical packages more
successfully
like i think we're in a better situation
if we have
uh 10 15 of the population that are
atheist scientific types
and why are you laughing i'm dead
serious
like if we have 10 15 of the population
when you have a football team you have
an offense and a defense right you have
different positions for different people
like it doesn't you can't form a
football team if you have
you know everyone is a quarterback that
team is not going to be successful
but i see a lot of our ancient
software is if we don't go kill the
tribe over the hill
they're going to come and kill us
therefore we
is we're in a safer world if everybody
is the same as us that that's
ancient ancient primal programming and a
lot of the
the disagreements that i see online are
people just advocating for their tribes
saying
i would feel much safer in a world where
everybody was christian or i would feel
much safer in a world
where everyone was lgbt or i would feel
much safer in a world where every
no one believed in in in religion
because they might become a suicide
bomber and end up on the bus that i'm on
this is this is really the dialogue that
we're having but
really the the system that we need to
work on
and and i think brett weinstein is is
brilliant
in illuminating this fact the system
that we need to work on is the system
that interfaces between the ethical
packages
because in certain ethical packages you
have kill all apostates
kill anyone who's not inside our group
that's a bad
thing because that that ethical package
becomes caustic to the rest of the
ethical packages
and it's helpful to have uh fit 10 to 15
of the population that's atheist
scientific types working on medical
advancements that everybody benefits
from
they don't necessarily believe in
evolution but when they show up at the
hospital
they have help there's help for them
there's help for them and their family
so
so what what is your position on
on that multi multiplicity of ethical
packages
so this is the thing this is also in
terms of
first of all like i said one of the
difficulties that religion is
is not first and foremost an ethical and
ethical
package it is it is a it is a communal
package it's a package which makes us
know that we are in communion with each
other that we have
things in common that help us to
see each other as together you could see
it that way
everything that you're saying goes along
with my beliefs maybe the term ethical
packages
no correct but and in that there's a
hierarchy of
practices sure yeah and so there are
things which are
high up on the normative ladder and
there are things which
are low on the normative ladder and
there are things which are considered
sinful now the thing about the sinful
part is that everybody
sins yeah it's not like there's a
particular type of person
that sins and everybody else doesn't
sin is just a normal part of reality and
so
the idea that certain behaviors are
prescribed as sinful
doesn't mean that they don't exist
because everybody sins and that's one of
the aspects of christianity is to say
don't judge your name don't judge the
other because you also have that in you
the way that you're framing this is
completely offensive to the atheist
types i want you to know
because you're you're basic um i'm
asking you about these
so much better though because you don't
have the totalitarian move
in what i'm saying there's no
totalitarian move because you can't say
so so are you saying now that the
atheists the atheists
like we're comparing a christian you're
i'm talking about the peaceful
cohabitation of the atheist tribe
and the christian tribe and you're
saying the atheist tribe is always going
to become totalitarian no not like how
is that
not always just 40 percent of the time
50
of the time no no no well what i mean is
that the idea of having a normal
hierarchy of
norm normativity is
the way that you kind of deal with this
stuff and so
and so the idea is that they're so let's
say in terms of sexuality
the id christian sexuality traditional
christian sexuality is radical
like it is very radical it says all
sexuality
even your thoughts has to be geared
towards uh a monogamous relationship
which is
in the pattern of of procreation
yeah like that's a great how can you not
see the evolutionary advantage of that
right exactly and also
everybody sins everybody falls short of
that
everybody no one doesn't fall short of
that
and so that's that's the way that
christians have approached it
and so the idea that in christian
societies there are always
behaviors which go outside of that that
goal
is just normal it's just going to happen
so so homosexual behavior has always
been part of christianity adultery has
always been part of christianity
masturbation has always been part of
christianity
it was prescribed but it was also
understood but you're everybody
is tainted by it everybody framing it
though as sin
as something that is missing the mark
framing it as sin though is offensive to
people who don't view it as sin
they have a different ethical pattern of
sexuality
well i listen in an evolutionary term
what's the mark
when do you hit the bull's-eye when you
when you return
grandchildren there you go yeah so
missing the mark
means going right aside from that but
they would the
the they would argue that they live in a
society where it's not necessary
for every single person to be churning
out children and that they might live a
more
meaningful life to them if they forgo
having children and have a same-sex
marriage or even not have a same-sex
marriage but screw around with every
single person that they come in contact
with
like maybe that's their uh beautiful
life their thriving life
uh the christians have been people who
do that it's that's not like yeah but
they are welcome inside the christian
they aren't welcome inside the christian
church though they
they're you think prostitutes don't go
to communion once a year
well okay my we're we're getting
away from my point here it might be no
it's important it's a really important
it's because we're so used to like weird
totalitarian systems
where we think that everything which is
illegal there's going to be a cop at
your door putting you in jail
but in normal societies that's not how
it works do you the fact that there are
prescribed
actions doesn't mean that they are all
enforced
through like force of police state if a
if a if a person wants to live
a lgbt lifestyle have a same-sex
marriage maybe adopt kids even
if they become a part of christianity i
don't necessarily think it's going to be
a comfortable
fit for them i mean i have friends that
are gay and catholic and just love it
so i mean it's definitely not without
the realm of
uh outside the realm of possibility i've
seen it happen
but uh it becomes a private question it
becomes a question of private
life and a private relationship with
your priest with your confessor
with you know it becomes something which
is not in the normative
uh prescription of the system but it
like i said we all have those it has
those things that aren't normative
it has entered the public sphere though
when you have
uh laws against gay marriage being
funded by the mormon church so
it definitely does enter the the public
space in ways that are not necessarily
good
in a utilitarian way for for everyone
well that depends what what exactly is
the purpose of gay marriage
the purpose of gay marriage is for
people for freedom liberty people to
be able to pursue the lifestyle that
they want the whole reason that we're
able
to have the purpose of marriage like
what what is what was the traditional
purpose of marriage
uh the body system like well in the
modern
no the traditional purpose was to have
kids but it's changed over time
now it's more the buddy system it's so
you have someone that you can share your
life with
so it's like yeah so it's basically
living together
with a contract is that yeah sure
yeah yeah a contract you know you're not
gonna
you're not gonna leave me it's the buddy
system
so but i mean you understand that
marriage
can can function in different ways as
well right
christianity has a specific way of
defining
marriage that works for christianity
that way of defining marriage is not
going to work
for everyone and what i'm saying is
it's better to have a world where we
have
different groups that pursue different
avenues of thriving and those groups
uh have a system for interacting with
one another that doesn't end up in
genocide
i agree with the last part so in terms
of not ending up in genocide
right but you also have to be careful
not to like
i mean i i'm not convinced i'm not so
diverse that it's like
chocolate pudding and then someone's
going to come in with a knife and
cut you up i'm not convinced that
if the shoe was on the other foot and
the lgbt community had the numbers
that they wouldn't genocide the
christian community
i'm not convinced that that wouldn't
happen yeah
well they can't have the numbers they
can't have the numbers because the lgbt
is
like five percent of the population yeah
no but i'm saying
like the the lgbt community is worried
about the christians genociding them
like they basically
but they have a they have total they
have reason to
my goodness yeah okay so we're in
agreement i totally agree
look i think that a lot of the stuff
that we're seeing now is because of an
excess of
of insane regulation that happened in
the 1950s and the early 20th century
like castrating chemically castrating
people and putting people in jail and
all this
insane stuff that happened in terms of
attacking people's lifestyles yes
exactly
that's crazy well i think that that is
what led to
uh to to to the movement and so i have a
lot of sympathy
for for what happened like i totally
understand you know i don't think i
think that in a normal
traditional world there's a lot more
flexibility
for people to live out their
idiosyncrasies
you know and it there isn't this like
weird police state enforcement of
people's
private lives like you know you just
there's
there's room like i said traditional
societies always had prostitutes like
prostitution is just part of you can
prescribe it and then also not
enforce not enforce it it just happens
this is part of society you say that's
taboo but it's still going to be there
and that's the same with
all kinds of other behaviors which have
always existed
from all time and so i think that the
the modern
clampdown on on the path pathologization
of homosexual behavior which happened
actually with scientific
reasons you know led to a crazy backlash
like
it was actually more the scientists that
ended up castrating homosexual than the
christians
the the the behavioral the all the
behavioral psychologists all of these
people who
who said that it was the disease that
needed to be they needed to be cured and
needed to be
you know that's a modern phenomenon it's
not an ancient phenomena the the system
that the thing that i'm talking about
the
system for interaction between
systems i think christianity has
an advantage on developing that system
because
it it has the one ethic
that is important that must be in this
like system to system uh management
ethics package basically and that is the
the love
thy neighbor or love thy enemy thing
because if there's any conflict between
those tribes like the
tribalism is so embedded in our
psychology that that tribalist
program takes over so quickly
that if you don't have that forgive the
enemy
ethic involved in your in your ethics
package there's no way
that you can stop that like we're down
the road
yeah to the next genocide so this is the
these are the things that i think you
know brett weinstein is talking about a
lot i think rationality rules
was talking about in your conversation
with them but not necessarily as
specifically
as i'm talking about them yeah but you
need you would need to
so if if you want to create something
which navigates a super system
let's call it the super system the
problem with the super system
is that it's it's being brought about by
people who
don't aren't aware that that that the
system is not arbitrary no
nobody's driving the ship now john
and so and so i i'm afraid of anybody
who wants to
place themselves above the systems like
i'm really afraid of that because
they have a blind they have a blind side
like they they're blinded by
by something and they think that they
can stand outside
we definitely want the right we want the
right people in charge of it i totally
agree with you
well actually it's better if they if we
don't have anyone in charge of it i
believe
in institutions like we need to build
institutions that allow
terrible people to that basically forced
terrible people
to do the right thing we want an
institution that's strong enough that
even if terrible people
grab the reins there's not too much
damage that they can do the
building institutions is the important
thing well for sure the u.s
the u.s system at least what seems like
that's what it was made for it yeah it
seems to
have lasted for a while it's it might be
it might be stretched don't talk like
that
don't talk like don't we're doing just
fine down here you're doing just fine
okay that's good sorry i'd have to stop
paying attention to
you to to what's being said on twitter
that's for sure
i only have about 15 uh 15 or 20 minutes
left
but i i want to talk about something
before we go because right you're in a
very
a very famous video with jordan peterson
and is it i think it's brett weinstein
where you're talking where brett
weinstein makes an argument and you guys
never really get back to the argument i
don't think brett weinstein even
finishes the argument but the argument
is that
the argument is what we're talking about
science is the super system
because science is the the way that we
mitigate between the
other systems i don't i don't know that
i totally agree with that science is a
component of the super system but the
super system
has to be has to have a moral component
as well and
we both know where science falls down
like science is
not prescriptive but descriptive yeah
exactly but the super system needs to be
proscriptive like obviously it has to
have
uh yeah it has all of our all of our
ethical packages are proscripted that's
the whole point of the ethical package
yeah it has to have it has to be able to
identify the good
towards which it's aiming yeah so you so
in that
in that talk just as just to sum it up
uh they were
uh you're you're talking about the
various systems christianity is one of
the systems but brett weinstein makes
the argument that science is the
is the highest the top of the hierarchy
and i know like you're
one of your things is hierarchy so i
could see oh he's getting triggered here
he doesn't like this it has to be
so i would think about this a lot i
think that a good way to understand
science let's give the background a
little more for people who haven't
necessarily heard at all
so do you were there that's why i'm do
you what what exactly happened there
well it was mostly about it was mostly
about this this idea
of the the problem because i did
i did a video on the the the idea of
metaphorical truth because he made it
brett made a video on metaphorical truth
where he talked about how he was saying
that
science is the higher truth science is
is above
the other truth right i was trying to
point into him the
the the performative contradiction which
is that he was using metaphor
to make science higher right you know
and i was and i was joking in the video
i said i said i looked at it on the top
shelf of my
of my room and i couldn't find science
like it just wasn't there
and so it's like i i if i stack science
on top of a pile of other things
it's like if you're if you go down into
the materialist scientific frame
this idea of a hierarchy just doesn't
make any sense so your your argument is
that
if you're going to make an argument that
science
is higher than metaphor you're literally
using a metaphor to make that
argument yeah i mean which is kind of
which makes sense so you're
saying metaphors are you saying but i
don't necessarily understand because i
understand brett's argument brett's
argument is
there are all these ethical systems uh
they all
believe different and contradictory
things science is the only one that can
discern truth among those things in a
materialist way
therefore if you are if truth
is really what you're looking for
because there's also well-being
like one system may be terrible at truth
but they are very good at well-being
like uh
the people who live there are very happy
none of them believe anything in the
real world but they're
so happy they're producing kids they're
thriving over time
uh so one of the things that i'm always
talking about is uh
the one of the ironies of the world is
where
like truth and well-being often diverge
so the antithesis community they want to
see
truth and well-being be on the same page
but it's that's not necessarily how the
world works
so but you understand the argument that
brett is making you're just making kind
of
technical i definitely disagree okay so
how do you disagree that's it
i disagree because the jump
between different levels of all reality
is not a scientific jump
there you cannot you have to take a
category for granted before you analyze
it
the ana the analysis of a category will
not give you the category but you
analyze it how because brett would say
so science science is
taking bounded taking bounded phenomena
and then
giving a description which is good
enough so that maybe you can predict
what's going to happen right and so you
you you bound to phenomena and then you
describe it in a way that is is is so
good that then
you can actually predict other versions
of it or how it's going to act let's say
all right it's going to
how it's going to continue right so that
is what scientific
things do but the category of a car is
not a scientific category
you need the category first before you
analyze the car
you need the category of a mountain
before you analyze a mountain
okay the world is fluid like the
boundaries between phenomena
are permeable but they're not they're
different ways to analyze a category
though
sorry there are different ways to
analyze a category
right but the the the scientist science
all it does is analyze the categories
for truth for truth categories are not
scientific
themselves science only and science only
analyzes for materialist truth claims
that's all it analyzes for
for it and you analyzes for factuality
yes right yeah but it doesn't it doesn't
give you
even the categories it's like
a river is not is that is a river is a
category of meaning
so if you're going to study what lives
in a river that that
a species are it's like why do we think
that species we have arbitrary not
arbitrary
we have meaningful ways of
differentiating species
but those are not in the you can't find
them in the
the the actual analysis of the category
what would be your rebuttal what would
be your argument
so uh or you're rebuttal to brett's
argument so if brett is saying
that science is the only way that you
can
study how the study the truth claims
between the various ethical systems
or religions whatever you want to call
them um
and he's saying that's why that's the
that is the defining factor of science
over the
different systems what you're saying no
science is you're saying
what is what is the highest is at the
bottom of the hierarchy but in a good
way
at the bottom of the hierarchy in a very
good way because what it does
is it helps you understand how things
work
right and so for example like the top
let's say a car at the top of the of
of a interacting with a car is
why does the car exist like it's the
ghost you need to
drive transportation is higher in the
hierarchy
transportation is higher
driving the car is higher in the higher
key than understanding how it works if
you don't understand how it works
obviously you're going to have a problem
driving it but the reason why you even
want to understand how the car works
is because you have a goal you have a
you haven't yeah utility hellos
yeah utility so what and so that's
that's what i think is higher it's just
inevitably higher on any hierarchy of
meaning has to be
purpose and goal and and the frame
of you know the category itself that
you're then
using science to to to decipher but
those categories are meaning categories
they're not
they're not you know you you don't
this is the problem of emergence you
can't you can't get to the higher level
being just by analyzing its parts
life cannot lay out the hierarchy
here with well there's
christianity is is a a system of
interacting
between people like an i identity of
of like you say uh a way that you're
going to
interact with the world and with other
people in christianity
and other people outside of christianity
like there's rules in christianity for
that as well
scientology is a different way of
interacting with people and
well it's it's just one of the packages
out there
and science is a is a different way of
interacting with people
and and the world there is a hierarchy
there that brett weinstein would say
science is at the top of the hierarchy
because science can explain the workings
of christianity
and of scientology in a way that
scientology cannot explain the workings
of science and christianity
what if this simple hierarchy of three
things where
you're saying science would be at the
bottom of that hierarchy and
christianity would be above it but where
does scientology fit in that hierarchy
the thing that's above the hierarchy is
the is the logos it's not
christianity okay so that's what i want
to get at right there so what's above
what is above all science scientology
and christianity what is that thing
well the divine logos like the divine
logos is
the is the reason
and origin and end of
things and those those that
you could see it as the highest version
but that scales down
all the way down to anything you can
identify
and so any every category
in terms of every category has a
and unity aspect to it right has
something which makes you know that it's
one
right even though it has parts okay
okay and so i know that that's hard it's
so hard i know we have to dumb it down
to atheist speak here you have to give
me the materialist version of it okay
because i
i understand how metaphors work it's not
a metaphor
it's not a metaphor in the in the simple
sense so so let's say
let's say you you um it's it's harder
for smaller things because people
because they see them physically
together so a chair is a good example so
there a chair has parts right yeah
oh and those parts also have parts yeah
no it's a conceptual case
okay so why do you think that a chair is
one thing
well it's based on the utility of the
chair obviously once
once a certain amount of matter
coalesces in a way
that it has a certain utility we start
categorizing it by that utility
i'm you're talking to a jordan peterson
fan here like obviously
the the we want the drill for what it
does we want the hole that the drill
puts in the wall
you don't care necessarily about the
drill it's about the utility
right and so that that is not a
scientific
description right the reason why
something exists
is not it's not is not a it's not a
scientific description of that thing you
could you could bring it into a
scientific description of something
above
it but not of the thing itself
what is the what is the utility
in categorizing the world this way
because jordan peterson
connects this way of categorizing
things to evolution he says
utility is what we're geared to look for
it's the same thing that donald hoffman
is talking about
donald hoffman is saying you know we
look at things by
their uh evolutionary advantage
they're like a point system so we don't
look at them
in a scientific way like we don't look
at the chair
and say you know break it down to its
parts we look at it as something that we
can use to sit on
yeah exactly but then that scales up
like way up
in the sense that it's easy for a chair
because the chair is physically
you can see it as physically together
but
uh uh let's say the category of all
chairs
are not physically together what right
but
but all chairs share an identity like
they they are
a body and they have a logos
which is above the individual chairs
right
and so that truth is higher than
the analysis of what a chair is made of
so you're saying what's at the top of
the hierarchy is
just the system that we categorize
things by it's the it's the reason the
ability to categorize
things yeah yeah something like that you
could i mean i could
i could go that far the ability to see
utility in things
or the inevitability of seeing utility
and things in the sense that
that's one of the reasons why they
appear to us as categories in the first
place
right because because there is no
there is no neutral reason to posit
categories
[Music]
well that's super interesting but
i mean that is this
thing that we do that we turn objects
into utility like our people have said
this for a long time like humans
that's what separates us from other
animals now
we realize that other animals use tools
all the time
i don't see how you can look at the
elaborate nests birds make and think oh
yeah we're the only species that uses
tools
yeah so but you're no i think logos
logos definitely goes down
into the chain what is specifically what
does logos mean specifically
it just means it means the reason
reason for things and the reason for
things appear
in the way that they're ordered so it
has to do with reason
in the sense that we understand and so
the the the order of something
so the order of something is bound up in
its reason right the
the order of the chair is bound up in
the reason why the chair exists
correct yeah the utility that it has in
the world
man we're making a utilitarian argument
here it's not a utilitarian argument
it's in my
in my vision it's more like a platonic
argument
because this this scales up in reality
because the thing the the problem with
the utilitarian argument is that it
nonetheless posits a neutral reality
is there anything above the
the uh category system in the hierarchy
yes okay oh my god god
okay that's what god does god is
is beyond category god is
infinite that's the one why the reason
why we say things like god is infinite
or god
is is beyond all name all
definition because god is the darkness
out of which
the categories come from the the the
divine darkness
god creates the categories god is the
impetus behind the categories
the god creates the categories through
the logos that's why we say in
christianity we say
you know i believe in one god the father
almighty creator of heaven and earth
and and it says that he created all
things through
the sun through the logos so god
god doesn't create directly because god
is beyond all categories
and so in in the in god there's
the there's a principle of manifestation
which then manifests the categories
and so beyond everything it's hard to
talk about this stuff man it's hard to
talk
so we don't have trying to talk about it
at a level that i hope
like like i know that now at this point
what we're talking about
people are gonna say okay sky daddy
fairy
tale exactly totally no you're on you're
on the right page
sadly it's good that you're it is good
john that you're self-aware
to note to know this because a lot of
people aren't necessarily self-aware
they don't even really know the other
side's arguments so they don't know what
the other side is thinking
so think about it at the chair level
let's go back up to the chair right so
you have a chair
right this chair has an order it has a
way for you to recognize that it's a
chair
yes yeah right that's that order is
bound up
in its purpose the way that the way that
you recognize though is in your head
it's not in the chair correct
what is the chair without the category
well
if you look at it like language we come
in what is the chair without the
category it's just a bunch of parts
and then those parts are also made of
parts it's just a quantum field without
a category
right but until somebody conceptualizes
it as a chair and uses it for the
utility
i mean that the category of chair
is inside our heads it's just i mean a
rock could be a chair
it will rock and function as a as a
seating place it's not really a chair
but it could function as
right think distance okay so i thought
you were talking more broadly like
something to sit on like anything yeah
yeah something
that's fine it doesn't matter what the
category is like it
they're they're hierarchies of
categories you know and so they they all
it's a dynamic hierarchy of categories
it's not just
they're not just one one and also
objects gonna have several
identities they don't have just one
right and so you can
when you if you if you take a rock and
you throw it at someone
it's not the same it's not the same
thing as the rock you're sitting on
are you even it's physically the same
are you familiar with transformation
which occurs when you pick the rock up
and bash someone over the head yeah
totally
the utility changes like it changes
categories how do you use it soon the
rock's a hammer
sue likes and the rock is a a sling
it's totally possible for that to happen
the
when you're this comes off a
bit like a presuppositional argument are
you familiar with pre-suppositionalists
no i'm not sure they have this argument
and i'm i'm not super
uh familiar with it either but their
argument is that
without a belief in god logic doesn't
exist
so therefore if you're using logic
you're basically admitting that god
exists which i i don't necessarily
understand
how they do the math on that one but
this comes off a little bit
like that like if you're using this
category system that i would argue is
just innate
in human psychology uh then you're
admitting that a god exists because the
god
the category system literally comes from
god you're saying
god is the top of the hierarchy and the
category it's not a mental
it's not a mental game it's an embodied
experience it's not as simple as just
saying when you believe
in god or whatever it's mostly that
that you you so the the problem is
always this
positing of something which exists
outside the category system
like what is this other thing that you
that you
that you posit that exists there is no
avoiding the categories no i agree i
agree the category system is
like an innate goes all the way down it
goes all the way down to
potentiality but i would argue in a
donald hoffman sense
that the category system is part of our
user interface with the world i would
argue that it's
operating inside our head that it
doesn't actually
exist what's that
he seems he posits another thing that he
has no access to
correct well he does have access to it
but only through the user interface
but he's saying that the user interface
uh strips out
so much information just
for people who are listening and they
don't know the donald hoffman argument
donald hoffman really quick
uh makes an argument that the real world
is
very different than the world that we uh
uh
see and understand that we
have uh what is effectively a user
interface a graphical user interface
like you use with your computer
many different operations are going on
inside your computer
than what we see on this depicted on the
screen we all understand the screen of
the computer very well
and he postulates that all of science
for as long as we've been studying the
natural world all we've been studying is
the screen the user interface and we've
never
looked inside the computer to what's
actually going on
so uh what we're talking about here is
i'm saying that that category system
is part of the user interface the screen
and not necessarily
uh i i i mean i don't want to speak for
you john are you postulating that god is
what is inside the computer
no i'm postulating that there there is
no
other there's only the screen
no that's not what i mean but what i
mean is that
you can posit as much as you want
another reality
that has ca that some kind of category
is behind the screen
but it's always categories yeah i agree
with manifesto
through meaning well the like so the way
that the categories are
the categories are essential to
us understanding the world as pixels are
on the screen like if you don't have
pixels you don't have a user interface
so so the the aristotelian or even
christian way of positing it would say
that
behind it is chaos potential it's a
potentiality
and then out of and then logos
light logos comes down on
potentiality and then forms identities
into that potentiality instead of those
identities are the realest thing
that because the potentiality is just
potentiality
instead of chaos could you say raw
materials
you could say raw i mean
i guess if you want well you're saying
all the way potential
possibility like it goes all the way
down to a field of
of of particles that are possibly
somewhere
right that are that are in flux let's
say we
i've got to wrap it up i know you have a
heart out too but this has been a
fascinating
we can talk again all right hopefully
like i but it's not giving me hope
that's for sure man really
oh yeah because i'm like i'm i'm
realizing just
how hard it is to communicate certain
things
to people who haven't had a certain
intuition like it's just really hard
to communicate it's like trying to find
words
in a language which is another language
it's difficult yeah i had
i had one of my uh one of my
fans watchers reach out to me and
they really like your stuff they really
wanted this conversation to happen
so and they your stuff has been super
meaningful to this
person so i know that you're making an
impact on people and people
people like your stuff and there are
people that understand it
i i guess one of my things is i'm just
i'm trying to bridge
that gap so many people see things that
they don't understand
and they have just like a visceral
disgust for it like they think that it's
a threat to their
identity or or whatever it is and i i
don't
i think that's just a bad way to look at
the world i think i i mean
you know obviously i i um you're a smart
guy i'm
i'm i'm trying to understand what you're
saying you're
you're well i i do i it's not like it's
completely a mystery to me and i feel
like uh what we've
articulated here has has been useful i
mean obviously
uh people leave comments on this people
will there are people on your side that
might be able to explain
things better that are uh to sort of
bridge that gap and
and same for you people on my on my side
might be able to
uh explain things a little more to you
so well i hope so i hope so
don't get frustrated though why why are
you don't get frustrated seriously
are you i think i'm frustrated with
myself like i'm frustrated
with the the the perception that there's
definitely like a wall
and it's like i and i know
and i know that it's a failure of my
capacity to communicate it
and so when i see the confusion in
someone's eyes i'm like damn
like i can see in your eyes it can
confuse you but there's no nothing wrong
with confusion though like confusion is
i mean that's what's wrong it's annoying
when you're trying to explain something
to someone and you see confusion in
their eyes
that's why i'm obviously not explaining
it the right way because then i wouldn't
see confusion in your eyes
confu confusion is how we begin any
engagement with a new topic i mean it's
that's normal that's completely to be
expected so
the thing that bothers me is not the not
not the fact that people are confused i
the thing that bothers me is people
are dismissive that's what bothers me
because there's absolutely no attempt to
even
even understand so yeah that's what bugs
me
well hopefully people won't be too
dismissive yeah well
this was a great conversation all right
i'm gonna talk to you man i'm going to
upload it to my channel i can send you a
copy if you want to upload it to your
channel too
so we'll see yeah i mean upload it send
me the link
and and i'll see how things go in the
next few weeks okay take care
it was great talking to you all right
bye bye bye